[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacré au liban alors qu'une équipe du
fmi est arrivé à beyrouth l'impact de la
crise économique sur les libanais et
sans précédent près de 80% de la
population vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté lourdement endetté le pays a
annoncé en mars 2020 le premier défaut
de paiement de son histoire le quotidien
des libanais ce sont des coupures
d'électricité des pompes à essence vide
une impossibilité de toucher à leurs
devises déposées à la banque le liban
aurait besoin théoriquement de 10 à 15
milliards de dollars selon le gouverneur
de la banque du liban après avoir
paralysé l'action du gouvernement le
hezbollah et son allié chiite du
mouvement amal ont annoncé qu'il
revenait à la table du conseil des
ministres
alors que peut faire le fmi à quelques
mois des élections législatives dans le
pays où en sont les enquêtes sur
l'explosion du port de beyrouth mais
aussi sur les pratiques de la banque du
liban qu une telle transparence est elle
possible au pays du cèdre que font la
france l'iran ou encore l'arabie
saoudite le fmi est il finalement le
dernier espoir des libanais on en parle
avec mes invités j'ai à mes côtés ben
hilal parabènes journaliste à france 24
également qui revient du liban qui
connaît très bien ce pays journaliste
franco libanais d'ailleurs bonsoir bilal
bienvenue dans l'émission nous avons
avec nous en duplex de beyrouth alia
moubayed bonsoir à vous économiste
spécialiste des pays émergents vous avez
participé à une étude à partir de
laquelle la france a d'ailleurs fait des
suggestions aux autorités libanaises
bienvenue dans le débat nous avons par
téléphone parce qu'il devait être par
skype mais il ya un problème de
connexion donc ça sera par téléphone
karim emile bitar bonsoir directeur du
département de sciences politiques à
l'université saint joseph de beyrouth
bienvenue également dans le débat
par skype également à casablanca cette
fois ahmed benchemsi bonsoir à vous
directeur de la communication pour le
moyen-orient et l'afrique du nord de
human rights watch
bienvenue à vous
avant de démarrer cette discussion va
faire un état des lieux en état les
lieux un peu économique du liban on va
voir quelques graphiques la dégringolade
d'abord de la livre libanaise ce qui a
perdu dégringolade de 90% depuis octobre
2019 donc c'est un effondrement
littéralement la devise libanaise grave
très grave - 90% une hyperinflation bien
sûr entraîné par cette dégringolade de
la monnaie libanaise une hyper inflation
de 2 181 % si vous prenez de juin 2010 9
juin 2021 sachez également que la
pauvreté a explosé 78% de la population
libanaise vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté c'est à dire c'est trois fois
plus qu'en 2020 on va écouter tout de
suite le président libanais michel aoun
c'était en décembre dernier docteur à
aller
des organisations du gouvernement est
responsable de la paralysie de
l'administration de l'état alors que les
employés attendent leurs droits les
hôpitaux leurs salaires et les
passations leur traitement
des cas les 1000 bitar il parle d'une
paralysie bien sûr du gouvernement
puisque pendant trois mois il ya eu un
boycott du hezbollah et de son allié
chiite du mouvement amal qui ont annoncé
ce week-end qu'il revenait à la table du
conseil des ministres
comment expliquez-vous pour donner un
peu de contexte karim emile bitar une
telle crise économique et financière qui
sont les responsables est ce que ce sont
justement ces autorités
les responsables sont très nombreux bien
évidemment les autorités libanaises qui
depuis plusieurs étés limite où on fait
preuve de corruption de négligence des
conférences crasse mais il ya aussi des
responsabilités qui sont plus larges
responsabilités liées à la dégradation
de la situation régionale de guerre par
procuration de plus en plus intense que
se livrent l'iran et l'arabie saoudite
au liban comme vous le disiez bien dans
votre introduction la situation se
dégrade véritablement de jour en jour
aujourd'hui les connexions internet sont
particulièrement faibles mon débit n'est
pas tout à fait suffisant pour que je
puisse avec ou un parc hype c'est pour
ça que vous avez un téléphone
malheureusement mais on vous a tout de
même
il en va ainsi dans tous les secteurs
dégradation de la situation sanitaire de
la situation scolaire de la situation
des télécommunications donc le liban est
véritablement en fin de course en
quelque sorte que le système politique
est totalement dysfonctionnelle les
parties se renvoient mutuellement la
balle personne n'assume ses
responsabilités et le fonds monétaire
international est peut-être la dernière
porte de secours seulement il est
combattu avec beaucoup de virulence par
une alliance d'intérêts qui vont du
hezbollah qui ne souhaite pas trop
l'immixtion des institutions
internationales il va aussi à des
intérêts privés libanais à certains
actionnaires de grands enfants qui ne
souhaite pas qu'on mette le nez dans les
malversations financières de ces pistes
15 dernières années donc il faut je
pense aujourd'hui se saisir de cette
opportunité pour reconstruire un nouveau
système politique un nouveau pacte
économique et permettre au liban de
retrouver sa souveraineté qui est
bafouée de jour en jour à m benchemsi
watch donc vient de publier son rapport
annuel et vous pointez dans ce rapport
vous pointez du doigt justement vous la
responsabilité des autorités je cite
corrompue et incompétente du liban qui
ont délibérément plongé le pays dans
l'une des pires crises économiques de
l'époque moderne faisant preuve d'un
total mépris pour les droits de la
population
les autorités sont donc selon vous
responsable de cette situation
catastrophique
oui et vous faites bien de souligner ses
passages parce que vous savez je suis
allé mais leur histoire depuis un
certain nombre d'années je peux vous
dire que l'on bout d'un moment on
s'habitue au langage d'organisation en
général on utilise des propos plutôt
mesuré la langage aussi les galères que
possible mais cette fois le rapport
annuel concernant le sur le liban a
explosé toutes les normes parce que la
situation hors norme on a parlé de
gestion défaillante des hommes
politiques on a parlé de corruption des
élites ce ne sont pas des choses qu'on
aborde généralement intérêts stricto
sensu ondes radio mais là ça dépasse
toutes les limites et ça les impacts sur
les droits humains on a parlé aussi d'un
jardin gérance politique flagrante sur
l' enquête de corruption concernant
l'explosion au port de beyrouth on a
parlé combler et le mépris total des
catégories entières de la population
voilà on est libre aujourd'hui et c'est
absolument désastreux vous le disiez
selon les nations unies plus de 80% du
pays dont 2 les habitants pardon n'ont
pas accès à des droits fondamentaux
comme le droit à la santé l'éducation ou
le droit à un niveau de vie suffisant
comme un logement adéquat ou
l'électricité vous parlez de dépression
délibéré l'expression des paquebots et
de la banque mondiale mais enfin on l'a
rejoint tout à fait les modèles a même
été jusqu'à classer la crise économique
libanaise comme les parmi les trois plus
grave crise financière depuis le milieu
du 19e siècle vous imaginez donc oui la
situation est grave à tous égards et
c'est une crise politique une crise
économique qui a bien entendu des
répercussions très importantes sur les
droits les plus fondamentaux des
libanais à savoir ceux de l'accès aux
denrées de base aux hôpitaux à la santé
à l'éducation et même un logement
adéquat à lien moubayed vous êtes
l'économiste de ce plateau est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu
simplement c'est que les banques se
rémunèrent est auprès de la banque
centrale avec des taux d'intérêt très
élevés des banques qui détiennent
d'après ce que j'ai lu 80% de la dette
publique libanaise
une dette publique qui représentait en
2010 970% du pib' libanais est ce que ça
veut dire que c'est un système bancaire
à système financier qui a fini par
exploser
tout à fait c'est en fait une crise
économique financière
aa composantes de faillite bancaire de
l'ain chocques de la balance des
paiements et du christ de dettes qui
s'est traduite par ce que vous avez bien
dit une
dévaluation
désordonnée de la delà de la livre
libanaise et qui a mené à
l'hyperinflation qui est une taxe
généralisée sur tous les nids ban et
quel que soit
leur niveau de revenu alors aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment la crise
qui a éclaté en 2019 madame qui est le
problème mais c'est en fait ce qui s'est
passé depuis d'octobre 2010 9 quand les
responsables libanais les politiques
libanais qui ne sont pas responsables en
fait ont laissé un pays a lui même
devant une crise comme a dit mon
collègue
au maroc une crise inédite
historiquement qu'on n'a jamais vues
dans les pays émergents moi je travaille
je travaillais sur sur des crises dans
des pays depuis
en asie en amérique latine mais
maintenant les crises auxquelles font
face beaucoup de pays jamais un
gouvernement n'a laissé son peuple sans
action la crise est une crise
manufacturés comme a dit monsieur le
rapporteur des nations unies récemment
en visite au liban siet ses sept pendant
deux ans la vole volonté de ne rien
faire
et c'est pas une inaptitude de ne rien
faire mais mais mais de laisser
l'économie sans fil sans filet de
sauvetage sans prise de décision que ce
soit pour sauver
pour mettre des des
des contrôles de capitaux pour aller
vers les organismes
internationale pour solliciter l'aide
les politiques libanais comme a dit
karim n'ont pas voulu
partager
le sort le sort
résoudre le problème libanais et ils ont
laissé le problème de l'économique
libanais ils ont laissé la situation
s'aggrave et s'aggravent en arriver
aujourd'hui à ces chiffres dont vous
avez mentionné aujourd'hui totalement
catastrophique bilal le quotidien des
libanais c'est de plus en plus difficile
donc on voit effectivement avec karim
emile bitar qui a pas de connexion
internet même à beyrouth deux heures
d'électricité par jour toute la jeunesse
veut partir toute la jeunesse est déjà
parti quasiment vous donner quelques
quelques chiffres sur alors il s'avère
que moi quand je vivais au liban les
partie d'un groupe de 10 amis proches en
moins de deux ans sur ces dix personnes
il en reste plus qu' il reste plus
qu'une qui vit au liban je lui parlais
il ya pas très longtemps et il me disait
que lui il était prêt aujourd'hui à
partir clandestinement vivre au royaume
uni donc ça je vous parle de personnes
qui font partie des sons classes
moyennes enfin cette fameuse classe
moyenne dont des cadets qui sont parus
au niveau de tel n'existe plus c'est
vous dire si vous voulez le déclassement
qui a autre exemple je connais des gens
qui sont partis vivre à lisbonne alors
lisbonne aux dernières nouvelles enfin
le portugal n'a jamais été un point de
chute de la diaspora libanaise il ya des
communautés donc libanaise qui se
forment à lisbonne ya des communautés
qui se forment dans les environs de
rotterdam
évidemment les libanais continue en tout
cas ceux qui le peuvent à partir dans
les pays du golfe c'est une vraie
hémorragie jusqu'avant parce qu'il ya
toujours une diaspora libanaise et non
non c'est à dire et puis surtout la
différence avec avant et quand je dis
avancer la période entre la fin de la
guerre civile en 91 et maintenant c'est
que les libanais partait travailler dans
leur vingtaine ou au début de la
trentaine mais pour rentrer au liban ils
se projetaient quand même là vous avez
des gens qui partent avec leur photo de
famille si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
armes et bagages et qui ne se projette
plus du tout pour retourner vivre
vivre libre ans et ça c'est une énorme
différence cette
élite enfin étudiante libanaise vous
voulez trilingue qui s'est longtemps
exporter elle est je pense en tout cas
si la situation n'évolue pas on a vienne
sera la dernière du pays avant avant pas
mal de temps on va écouter riad salamé a
le gouverneur de la banque du liban
c'était il y a un an
il faut rétablir la confiance et à trois
piliers pour cette conférence la
première c'est de faire un budget qui
représente moins de déficit il faut
négocier avec les créditeurs parce qu'il
ya eu de la part du gouvernement une
décision de ne pas payer les dettes
internationales
deuxièmement il ya la réforme du secteur
bancaire que nous avons commencé en tant
que banque centrale et troisièmement il
ya la parité de la livre libanaise qui
nous devons sortir de ce système où il
ya trois prix et de la spéculation pour
profiter de démarches cliente ces trois
pays karim emile bitar depuis riad
salamé depuis donc sous le coup d'une
enquête pour détournement de fonds
publics il faut le dire qu'attendez-vous
du fmi justement lui dit riad salamé que
il essaye de mettre en place un certain
nombre de réformes or le fmi demande une
expertise judiciaire comptable à la
banque centrale et aux différents
ministères à ce qu'une telle
transparence est possible au liban
malheureusement je crains que ce ne soit
pas le cas monsieur à la mais est encore
en poste aujourd'hui alors même que des
enquêtes sont diligentées contre lui en
france en suisse ou au liechtenstein au
luxembourg peut être demain en grande
bretagne il est encore à son poste est
précisément parce que c'est l'homme qui
ont fait trop où il détient tous les
secrets de la caste politico mafieuses
de cette oligarchie financière qui
gouverne le pays depuis 30 ans il a
rendu des services importants à la
france mais aussi aux chefs de dollars
qui l'a aidé à détourner les sanctions
américaines rendu des services à la
plupart des membres
classe politique libanaise si
aujourd'hui son bloc pour le protéger
donc il parle de transparence la
première restructuration n'était pertes
et la restructuration des banques la
restructuration à l'intérieur de la
banque centrale qui est qui a fait
preuve d'une très grande opacité sur ses
chiffres depuis les dernières années
monsieur salamé a mis en place d
ingénierie financière qui font sauter au
plafond tous les experts de la planète
il a essayé de gagner du temps depuis
2015 2016 il est protégé par une sainte
alliance de politiciens mafieux et de
banquiers véreux qui ont tous intérêt à
repousser sur le peuple libanais les
pertes pour ne pas se focaliser en
quelque sorte leurs pertes après avoir
privatisé d'énormes profits pendant les
trente dernières années donc les
réformes structurelles elles sont
connues telles que le fonds monétaire
internationale préconise c'est la
réforme de l'électricité
ce sont des réformes fiscales ce sont
des réponses qui vont au coeur du
système libanais l'économie libanaise
était une économie de rente les libanais
ont vécu au-dessus de leurs moyens le
temps est venu de reconstruire une
économie il soit une économie du savoir
qui se focalise sur les secteurs
productifs créateurs d'emplois sur
l'agriculture sur l'industrie nous avons
vécu dans une bulle pendant une
quinzaine d'années bulle a éclaté
aujourd'hui il est absolument impératif
que le fonds monétaire international et
la communauté internationale en général
ne donne plus d'oxygène à une classe
politique corrompue jusqu'à la moelle et
au contraire qu'elles imposent des
conditionnalités extrêmement strictes
car le liban a reçu des plus intérieur
des plus de financements extérieurs
impressionnant pendant 20 ans
l'équivalent du plan marshall qui a
reconstruit toute l'europe et ces sommes
se sont évaporés grâce à cette élite et
élite prédatrice qui est au pouvoir au
liban bon tout est encore le liban et le
livre absolument besoin du fonds
monétaire international il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de plan b mais il faut
traiter soit conditionnelle et que des
réformes structurelles doit imposer par
la communauté internationale autrement
tout cet argent sera dilapider ce sera
comme le tombeau des danaïdes ah oui
ahmed benchemsi vous êtes d'accord
justement avec ce que vient dire karim
emile bitar le problème dans votre
rapport justement de human rights watch
vous écrivez la communauté
internationale devrait utiliser tous les
outils dont elle dispose pour presser
les décideurs politiques libanais dont
vous dit la même chose que ce que vient
de dire karim emile bitar mais cette
pression du fmi est ce qu'elle va être
suffisante est effectivement ça à faire
bouger les choses
une la communauté internationale un fait
ce qu'elle peut avec les outils dont
elle dispose mais effectivement à ce
stade nous pouvons que constater
l'incurie de l'élite politique
économique y malaise et appelé à ce que
des gens et des institutions en dehors
du liban bouge prenons l'exemple de
l'explosion de beyrouth par exemple
c'est le monde entier on lui parlait
c'était une des explosions des plus
importantes de ce début de siècle non
nucléaires
le
219 personnes ont été tuées des
centaines de handicap et 7000 personnes
blessées après après la moitié de la
ville qui a été détruit d'une manière ou
d'une autre et encore aujourd'hui
personne n'est tenu responsable par la
justice alors qu'on est conscient on
l'enfoncé on sait ça a été documentée
que certains membres du gouvernement
étaient conscients du risque pour la vie
humaine mais qu'ils ont laissé faire ce
qui est une violation des droits ce qui
s'est passé ce qui est injuste qui
étaient nommés qui saigne a convoqué les
anciens ministres à les inculper et
alors le système sectaire libanais s'est
mise en branle ça a même abouti à des
tirs dans la rue ce qu'on n'avait plus
vu depuis la guerre civile et et au
final enquête n'a toujours pas avancé
d'un pouce sans parler des vices de
procédures et des défaillances
systémiques portes du coup forcément
nous ont réalisé vendredi à mâcon ce
qu'on se dit andy bas le système n'est
pas capable de se réguler tout seul il
n'est pas capable de délivrer une
justice normale et on en appelle au
conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies pour faire une enquête
pour pour en lieu et place la justice
libanaise c'est ne pas le genre de chose
qu'on demande d'habitude on respecte la
souveraineté des états des systèmes
nationaux mais là c'est plus possible
quand on voit le niveau de gabegie et
les conséquences que ça sur le quotidien
des libanais al yah moubayed justement
riad salamé disait que le liban avait
besoin entre 12 et 15 milliards de
dollars pour relancer son économie est
ce que c'est une manne financière que
pourrait apporter le fmi et à quel prix
parce qu'on connaît les thérapies de
choc du fmi est ce que c'est ce type de
thérapie qu'il faudrait mettre en place
à au liban pour restructurer la dette
par exemple
je pense que le cas libanais c'est un
cas très
exceptionnels et c'est un cas qui va
être un grand défi pour l'organisme pour
le comme le fonds monétaire
international parce que je ne pense pas
que que l' approche pour résoudre le
problème libanais peut être une approche
classique
du fonds monétaire c'est-à-dire
austérité
conditionnalité etc il ya à la fois
premièrement un grand un problème que le
financement du fonds monétaire tout seul
ne peut pas
pour lequel n'est pas suffisant le liban
a besoin de recapitaliser ses banques
de dunes d'un besoin en financement
annuel d'au moins 10 milliards par an
donc on parle de grandes sommes dont le
fonds monétaire tout seul est incapable
de résoudre dont pays l'eau il doit y
avoir une coopération avec des bailleurs
de fonds bilatéraux et cela bien sûr va
impliquer des pays comme les pays du
golfe où les pays européens et donc
premièrement il ya un problème un grand
problème que le fonds monétaire ne peut
pas résoudre tout seul deuxièmement il
ya un problème politique de légitimité
comme a dit car ni les
ceux qui vont
déposer ou formuler le problème de
sortie de crise sont ces mêmes
politiques actuellement ce gouvernement
actuel qui aux yeux de beaucoup de
libanais manque de légitimité qui a
participé à amener le dit le liban au
bout de la crise et qui comme j'ai dit
auparavant qui a laissé les libère des
souffrir pendant deux années or ça c'est
un problème qui va être perçue si le
fonds monétaire va va travailler avec
cette ce gouvernement où cette classe
politique chapeauté par cette classe
politique même il y a un problème de
légitimité de légitimiser l'intervention
du fonds aux yeux des libanais même qui
contestent le pouvoir en place et
troisièmement il y a un problème de mise
en place de toute réforme une fois si
jamais on se met d'accord sur un
programme de réformes cette fois aussi
cette classe politique a détruit les
institutions libanaises et notamment les
institutions comme ministère des
finances la banque centrale
est vide et de capacité de travail et
cela en lui même va poser dans le futur
un problème de mise en exécution de
toutes de toute réforme donc il ya un
problème à la fois de
technique et de snacks ou deux niveaux
d'intervention requis que le fonds
monétaire ne peut pas tout seul faire
deuxièmement un problème de légitimité
politique parce qu'on a besoin d'une
acceptation sociale d'une participation
un peu
élargie de l'opinion publique libanaise
assez assez assez assez sacrifice est
nécessaire futur il ya un problème
d'exécution auquel le fonds monétaire va
faire face est un grand risque de
réputation pour une enquête pour un
organiser soi-même le fonds monétaire à
mon avis risque de réputation vous dit
bilal c'est vrai que réputation parce
qu'il va travailler comme a dit karim
avec une j'ai compris je voulais faire
rebondir justement mafieuses voilà c'est
ce que vous disiez casse mafieuse
problème de réputation bilal les
autorités libanaises ne rentrent jamais
de comptes en fait c'est ça aussi le
problème
cette enquête justement qu'on évoquait
du juge bitar sur l'explosion du port de
beyrouth cette enquête a été suspendu
trois fois me semble-t-il cette enquête
sur riad salamé justement le gouverneur
de la banque du liban là aussi elle bute
sur le secret bancaire libanais ils ne
rendent jamais de comptes non ils
rentrent jamais être content karim bitar
quand
pardon tarek bitar homonyme quand il a
le quand il a le droit d'enquêter ça
dure généralement quelques semaines
jusqu'à comme un de nos intervenants l'a
rappelé jusqu'à ce que des hommes
politiques fassent blocage or pour être
très concret il ya une vingtaine de
personnes qui sont quand même en prison
au liban dans le cadre de cette enquête
ça remonte jusqu'à un ancien directeur
des douanes et un ancien directeur du
port en revanche dont tous tous ces gens
qui qui sont qui sont en détention sont
vraiment des fonctionnaires à des petits
ou et des niveaux intermédiaires ou en
tout cas des gens qui ont eu des
fonctions je vais dire très technique
quand on en arrive volet des
responsabilités politiques c'est là que
ça coince puisque hawking aucune des
personnalités cac a convoqué le juge
bitar n'a daigné se présenter et
d'autres et ça notre ami de human rights
watch la rappeler à
d'autres qui sont inculpés vont jusqu'à
manipuler les foules et provoquer des
affrontements armés dans beyrouth mois
juste pour la petite anecdote la
dernière fois que j'étais à beyrouth
donc il y avait le juge bitar qui
voulait convoquer le directeur de la
sûreté générale qui s'appelle abbas
brahim qui est le pur va dire le
policier en chef au liban et qui est
surtout un émissaire assez important
dans les dents les affaires étrangères
libanaise bon vous rouliez dans le sud
de beyrouth et dans les zones sunnites
donc parce que abbès brahim et sunnites
et vous voyez des immenses portraits
alors du moment où tard et que bitar le
juge bitat a décrété sa convocation vous
voyez d'aider des portraits géants au
bord des routes en 4 par 3 le long de
cet axe qui part de beyrouth jusqu'au
sud avec des loges à la gloire de abbès
brahim est presque des poèmes comme quoi
il apportait le le bonheur à la classe
vibrations de faire pression oui c'est
exactement ça c'est pour le port de
beyrouth maintenant parler de ryadh
sallem et riad salamé il faut savoir
qu'il est déjà sous le coup d'une
enquête en france le parquet national
financiers a décidé en juillet de
l'année dernière de d'examiner d'enquêté
sur le patrimoine de riad salamé
et a ouvert une enquête contre x je vous
cite pour blanchiment en bande organisée
et association de malfaiteurs c'est
assez explicite l'un nos intervenants
nous avait aussi évoqué des avoirs de
ryadh sallem et en europe figurez-vous
que l'année dernière il ya eu une
réunion à la haye de magistrats qui
venait de à peu près tous les pays
d'europe dans lesquels ryadh sallem est
supposé avoir de l'argent raccrochée
vous parce que la liste est assez longue
le liechtenstein le luxembourg la grande
bretagne l'allemagne et la suisse et
enfin riad salamé a été cité dans les
pandora paper et pour la petite anecdote
comme le premier ministre actuel et
comme son prédécesseur et enfin oui au
liban il ya plusieurs enquêtes qui
concerne les
patrimoines de riad salamé avec de
multiples interférences là karim emile
bitar emmanuel macron en tout cas pour
parler de la france puisque on va parler
des autres ce qu'ils doivent participer
à cette aide au liban il a reçu premier
ministre libanais mikati au palais de
l'elysée c'est en septembre dernier
emmanuel macron s'était personnellement
engagé dans ce dossier afin d'amener le
pays du cèdre à mener des réformes le
succès est totalement mitigé ça n'a pas
abouti
oui force est de reconnaître que
l'initiative macron s'est heurté à une
pire croisé venant des deux bords de
l'échiquier politique libanais cette
initiative est aujourd'hui
mourante même si la france continue nous
rendre visite
oui oui elle est en en fin de course
même qui a beaucoup de diplomates qui
continuent à s'activer avec un certain
dynamisme et une certaine persévérance
parce qu'il ne souhaite pas abandonner
le liban mais la classe politique
libanaise n'aurait jamais accepté cette
initiative car elle impliquerait de les
voir se dessaisir des principales
manettes du pouvoir législatif
économique la véritable solution aurait
été un gouvernement avec des
prérogatives législatives exceptionnel
monsieur macron n'a pas réussi à imposer
cela à l'oligarchie libanaise
aujourd'hui il faut poursuivre des
efforts surtout pour sortir de cette
culture de l'impunité cas évoqués ahmed
benchemsi on a vu dans la sphère de riad
salamé dépression du 1er mai pour
entraver les enquêtes dans la sphère du
port de beyrouth des pressions du
hezbollah et ce qui est frappant c'est
qu'on se rend compte que les deux seules
véritables partis qui sont huit ans au
liban et de parti de dieu le hezbollah
est ce qu'on appelle ici le parti des
banques c'est-à-dire des intérêts
financiers qui ont d affiner dans tous
les partis politiques communautaires et
ce sont ces deux parties qui entravent
la justice et aujourd'hui il est temps
de rompre le pacte faustien pendant une
vingtaine d'années le hezbollah disait
ne vous occupez pas de mon arsenal
militaire de fermeraient les yeux sur
votre corruption et de l'autre côté on
s'accommoder cela on a monté un système
financier sur des bases sur des sables
mouvants qui a fini par s'effondrer donc
aujourd'hui il est temps de mettre les
deux sujets simultanément sur la table
le sujet de la souveraineté libanaise et
de plus en plus
foulé aux pieds par certains
comportements du hezbollah et
parallèlement le thulliez des réformes
structurelles politiques et économiques
dont le liban a besoin pour se
débarrasser de fête élites prédatrices
le maire justement pardonnez moi karim
emile bitar comment fait-on alors qu'ils
sont tous et d'ailleurs le hezbollah et
amal bloqué boycotté le gouvernement
donc le gouvernement était totalement
bloquée aujourd'hui sont tous à la table
des négociations ils sont tous à donc
comment vous faites
alors précisément ils sont tous en train
de faire bloc pour se soutenir les uns
les autres même s'ils vont des
divergences sur les questions
géopolitiques comme disait voltaire
lorsqu'il s'agit d'argent on est tous de
la même religion dès qu'il s'est agi de
tortiller le plan de sauvetage
économique qu'ils étaient tous d'accord
pour torpiller le plan établi par le
gouvernement précédent avec la banque
lazard aujourd'hui il est nécessaire
qu'il y ait également une union sacrée
de toutes les forces réformatrices de
tous ceux qui veulent se débarrasser de
cette oligarchie qui est au pouvoir
depuis 30 ans et ce n'est que en
réussissant à l'heure mais à maintenir
la pression sur le front syndical sur le
front des élections législatives sur le
pont professionnel au dans les milieux
universitaires et sociaux c'est un
combat de longue haleine pour changer la
culture politique libanaise est arrivé
un système politique qui soit fondé sur
la citoyenneté et et non plus sur le
partage des dépouilles entre des chefs
communautaires et des miliciens qui se
sont auto à munich et en 1991 ils ont
voté à la sauvette une loi d'aministie
absolument scandaleuse et on se retrouve
trente ou quarante ans après avec les
mêmes figures en train de se partager le
même gâteau dont il ne reste plus rien
donc le temps est venu aujourd'hui de
rassembler toutes les forces libérales
réformatrice pour se débarrasser de
cette caste dirigeante et refonder un
système politique sur une économie
productive les principes de base de la
souveraineté est un minimum de justice
sociale dans un pays où les inégalités
sont de plus en plus criant ahmed
benchemsi vous êtes d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire karim emile bitar mais
comment faire parce que d'ailleurs dans
votre rapport vous le dites que vous
avez bien regardé cette enquête vous
avez fait une enquête sur l'explosion de
beyrouth de du 4-août 2020 et vous dites
que vous avez découvert donc c'est human
right watch des éléments qui tendaient à
prouver que certains responsables
gouvernementaux avaient connaissance des
risques mortels que posait la présence
dans le port de stock de nitrate
d'ammonium et qu'ils avaient tacitement
accepté ces risques donc c'est contre
lui mais alors absolument tout à fait on
l'a on l'a démontré c'est pas juste de
la négligence il n'est pas encore au
moment il savait tout à fait et ils ont
laissé faire alors pourquoi ils ont
laissé faire je ne sais pas je ne veux
pas spéculer mais enfin hier aucune
raison acceptable quant à ce qu'il faut
faire je laisse mon ami karim emile
bitar nos autres collègues qui sont
présents sur ce plateau s'exprimant à la
place ils sont libanais il s'est
beaucoup mieux que moi est ce qu'il faut
faire pour aider la situation mais il
est évident qu'il faut quelle que soit
la forme que ça prend réformer
totalement la vie politique libanaise
sur la base sur une base qui soit plus
respectueuse des droits des gens parce
que on la presse de crise économique on
a parlé de crise humanitaire est alors
le bourg est il qu'au vide aussi qui
s'ajoute à tout ça et alors le bouquet
en plus de toutes ces multiples crises
qui se superposent les unes aux autres
c'est que la liberté d'expression se
dégradent ça aussi on en parle dans
notre rapport en même temps que tout ça
arrive on a documenté l' usage par les
forces de sécurité de violence
absolument excessive pour disperser des
manifestations parfois il y des tirs à
balles réelles c'était pas la norme mais
ça ça s'est quand même fait un mort
parmi les manifestants et deux blessés
les renseignements militaires qui font
disparaître et qui torturent des
manifestants 35 qui se retrouvent en
procédant deux enfants pour terrorisme
même parfois les journalistes qui sont
de plus en plus critiqué donc vous avez
reims d'un système qui implosent qui
complètement rongée par le sectarisme la
népotisme et la corruption
et malgré tout ça
une espèce de collusion de ses élites
corrompues pour maintenir une chape de
plomb sur la population non seulement
elle a pas de quoi manger suffisamment
de quoi subvenir à ses besoins à ses
droits de base mais en plus elle a même
pas droit à s'exprimer il réellement
temps de refonder le liban sur des bases
complètement différent alia moubayed
pour en revenir justement à la france
vous vous avez transmis votre rapport
économique à la france à emmanuel macron
et vous aussi vous concluez que ça n'a
pas abouti
ce rapport que nous avons fait avec
beaucoup d'économistes
sait il y en a plusieurs c'était de
présenter aux politiques libanais mais
aussi à la communauté internationale des
solutions au début de la crise pour
éviter d'arriver jusque là or maintenant
deux ans après il faut tirer clairement
la leçon que ceux qui sont en charge
maintenant de mettre à nouveau un plan
de sauvetage qui va ressembler
certainement à ceux qui à celui qui à ce
plan qui a été
donc on a fait le sabotage il y à il y à
il ya presque 10 mois sont incapables de
mettre en oeuvre ses réformes et et
c'était clair pour nous non seulement il
savait ce qu'il fallait faire et que ne
l'ont pas fait alors comment allons-nous
accepter de leurs 2 2 les deux l'égard
des responsables pour le futur ils ont
déjà été responsable de la destruction
de dresde aulas dans des mois sans les
élections et données peuvent changer les
choses par exemple
beaucoup à nous faire confiance à les
potentats
je pense que c'est que c'est que c'était
un élément essentiel dans dans une
longue dans une longue trajectoire de
changement cumulatif dont on a besoin
mais donc ce qu'on a besoin aussi c'est
que la communauté internationale dont la
france
ne qui est on comprend bien qui est
fatigué du poids lourd du fardeau et du
problème libanais ne prennent ce
problème de crise et qu'on va vers pour
le donner à fond monétaire en pensant
que ça va se résoudre en lui-même ce
n'est pas en lançant le liban dans un
programme avec le fonds monétaire qu'on
va résoudre un problème multi
multi dimensionnelle et qui a
essentiellement un problème de bonne
gouvernance ce dont on a besoin
c'est d'insister à la fois comme
libanais comme et comme bailleurs de
fonds d'asseoir ce programme tout
programme du fonds de dans le futur de
l'encré dans des réformes de bonne
gouvernance dans une justice
indépendante qui est capable de
s'assurer qu'il y ait une qu'il n'y ait
plus d'impunité comme a dit karim bitar
et comme le dit heitz watch dans son
rapport
dans un système institutionnel qui
garantit une bonne gestion des deniers
publics ce qui n'est pas le cas jusqu'à
lors donc ils vont bien asseoir ce
programme du fonds dans ses principes
essentiels sinon ça va très très
difficile de convaincre les libanais de
faire des sacrifices a encore
additionnel hélas le liban est aussi
écartelée entre l'iran et l'arabie
saoudite 1 j'ai vu que le hezbollah
avait envoyé des navires de carburant
iranien pour ravitailler le liban l'été
dernier derrière les etats-unis avaient
répliqué avec justement l'acheminement
du gaz enfin voit bien que ce pays est
dépendant à la fois de l'iran alors
l'arabie saoudite a l'air beaucoup plus
lointaine aujourd'hui la france on voit
que eh bien ça n'a pas abouti
oui d'ailleurs juste en parlant diront
je vais me lever moto corriger une
seconde tout à l'heure je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai dit que le directeur de la
sûreté générale était était sunnite il
est chez bon bref passons en fait c'est
pour pour comprendre si vous voulez tout
ça j'aimerais si vous me le permettez
n'a plus beaucoup de temps alors revenir
à un tout petit peu grosse et très très
rapidement le l'origine du problème au
moment de la si vous voulez de la
création du oui parce que là c'est plus
en parle plus de l'iran aujourd'hui oui
l'iran aujourd'hui en design et l'iran
aujourd'hui utilisent le hezbollah comme
un pion à tel point que des gens
considèrent que le liban est presque
cazine colonne iranienne l'arabie
saoudite qui pour des raisons
personnelles à financer pendant des
années la classe politique libanaise ne
le fait plus tout simplement parce que
ça ne rapporte pas d'argent le problème
c'est que l'arabie saoudite et l'iran
est en conflit dans la région si vous
voulez les hommes politiques libanais
écartelé entre des allégeances qui ne
sont pas nationales et c'est ça le
problème mais qui vont à l'un ou à
l'autre provoquent des des mesures si
vous voulez de 2,2 des punitions sur le
pays que ce soit de l'arabie saoudite en
arrêtant ses financements que ce soit de
l'iran en créant une insécurité
permanente au liban il nous reste deux
minutes karim emile bitar est-ce que
vous pensez que les élections qui vont
venir pour changer la donne et est ce
que ce fmi représente une forme d'espoir
tout de même
les élections sont les pépères mais
elles ne sont pas la panacée le people
bien verrouiller les partis politiques
traditionnels concerts de soutien et
encore beaucoup des prix qu'affichent le
fmi représente peut-être par les x men
opportunité de remettre à plat ce
système il faut que les réformes
économiques de la vie aille de pair avec
des réformes permettant aux dépens de
recouvrer sa souveraineté bilal a mis le
point sur quelques fautes fondamentale
la nécessité de sortir le liban de son
statut des papes en pont de la jop
vernet tionale de se désengager de cette
guerre des régionaux les projets à la
projection de conflits extérieurs sur la
situation libanaise est proprement
dramatique à tous les points de vue donc
oui le fmi représente une opportunité ne
serait ce que parce que ça impose aux
parents ce ne serait que cela imposera
paradoxalement plus de justice sociale
alors qu'en occident le fmi est certes
eu comme le grand méchant loup
au liban on en est arrivé à un point où
le fmi est un peu paradoxalement le
défenseur de la veuve et de l'orphelin
par rapport à cette caste prédatrice et
au pouvoir au liban ce qui veut dire au
niveau mois par amp et de leurs alliés à
mumbai est juste pour conclure justement
sur le fmi c'est un espoir tout de même
une opportunité comme dit karim emile
bitar
absolument c'est une opportunité et ça
revient à la premièrement on y va les de
la saisir en se mettant d'accord sur un
preux un projet de réforme qui est
développé par les libanais pour les
libanais on a à la fois les capacités il
y a une opinion publique qui acquit qui
sait ce qu'elle veut et il faut tout
d'abord s'assurer que ça doit être un
projet
participatif dans le qu'ils ne se soient
pas qu'il ne soit pas en train de ce2
ce2 se préparer dans les chambres noires
tel que nous le voyons
ces jours ci voilà on attend beaucoup du
fmi malgré tout merci beaucoup et
remèdes benchemsi d'avoir été avec nous
merci karim emile bitar merci à vous
alia un moubayed merci à bilal vilalta
rabais journaliste à france 24 merci à
vous tous nous avoir suivis reste avec
nous sur france 24
[Musique]